that's not the plan all right we are in
Las Vegas
we're here because
my friend blueface
is on house arrest
we saw a couple weeks ago you got picked
up
made bail rather quickly
we're supposed to do this in L.A and
you're like man come hey come to Vegas I
can't leave yeah we have plans the day I
got arrested we were supposed to do this
yeah I thought I was gonna make it out
of court blueface it's uh good to see
you uh not incarcerated thank you
brother you do have the uh the bracelet
on your ankle currently
um and we are in Las Vegas and we have
the first artist on milk music MILF
music your baby mama
she is here
Jaden
yeah uh she distracted her new song
Stewie yeah like two days ago what you
think you think she's The Last Story
I think she looks like drewski really
[Laughter]
yeah I think it's funny but do you look
like do you see like do you see what
everyone else sees like I could be his
little sister maybe
I mean maybe I don't know
um no but I see I get the Stewie thing
see I like the self-deprecation that's
all I'm a white guy so all we do is
self-deprecate so I like the fact okay
because I have a giant head all my
friends make fun of me because you do
gotta be here actually when we go to
that like look at this there's a reason
why I wear a hat like I'm domed up bro
um but uh yeah the Stewie thing is I
think it's funny I think I mean [__] I
don't I don't give a [__] yeah I mean
why not so when you like because listen
obviously you have been
you have been on in some sort of
Spotlight due to your you know
relationship with blue over the last you
know three or four years right yeah
we've seen a lot of drama a lot of
craziness you put your paws on people
um
I feel like I just just went on a
YouTube diving so I don't know it could
be wrong I could yeah I might have I
might have um but I'm curious let's just
get back to the beginning how did you
guys initially meet up because you were
like baby mama Uno right right so you're
the first one
you're the OG the OT
um how did you guys do that let's take
it back how did you guys first meet uh
we went to high school together okay we
met in high school
and uh was this when he was playing
football yeah a little football star or
whatever so you're the football star and
then you got like do you guys go to prom
together yeah yeah we went to yours yeah
oh so you guys did go to prom yeah oh
nice how was prom did you guys have sex
in prom
after yeah I don't know you know not
that prom yeah
wow in and out High uh and so
give me kind of because for you like
um
there's been so much
controversy regarding Blues
relationships in general yeah period
um I feel like you've you know you had
to have dealt with a lot of
difficult situations to pay to pay
attention to online or not pay attention
to like do you land a lot of the
comments or a lot of the
stuff people say about you maybe a
relationship because obviously you have
a kid like right yeah
um I don't let it bother me I mean I
think because like I know what it is in
real life it's kind of like the internet
just they see one little 25 and they
make it into like 110 so I don't I don't
let what they say bother me
um blue for you is this MILF music thing
a real thing
I think I think we'll get more talent
coming in space stuff here
impression you know so in order to be on
your new label you have to have child
yeah you gotta have a kid like what's
the option for auditioning Baby Daddy
has to be a reference like he asked
about you so it doesn't have to be your
baby Mama's only on no music it could be
anybody who's got children yeah yeah
definitely can you be pregnant yeah yeah
what if someone's just expecting are you
pregnant you could be okay so that
qualifies
all we got to know is you got you got
something to lose you know you got
something to live for you got something
to die for you're not just like taking
advantage of the situation so you
obviously have been in relationships
with uh women who you've started their
rap careers obviously questions just
performed the other night I saw her she
fell I mean I hope she's all right
um
how did you start rapping like did you
convince her or what like
okay so um
one day I just came I walked in the
house and she was like
let me try it like okay he didn't just
walk in we were we were drinking it
wasn't like it was just like hey how you
doing okay
no I mean yeah he came over one day he
was drinking and I was just like put me
in like let's go and then he was like
for real I'm like yeah let's see like
how it goes how long ago was that that
was probably like a month ago so a month
ago so yeah it was like recently so for
you do you kind of see like the like
okay because we can't like the elephant
in the room is krishan's a star right
she's huge and you I mean that's a lot
to do with you obviously right do you
see that and say hey I could do that but
I could do it better
um
like let me give it I'm not sure I mean
there's no traffic if you in your own
lane like I'm not really like in a
competition with nobody
cop that [__]
no I'm I'm just saying I'm not in a
company with nobody wasn't like that at
all at all she was always been a fan of
music though right I like pay attention
to more artists but she never like told
me give me so like when I heard it I was
like so it's like the way I see is like
say if I'm the dope man right I'm never
gonna like insist on you getting in the
game and selling dope but if you come to
me like yeah man I want to get some
money
I'm gonna get here yeah here take this
though let me see what you do today so
it was that kind of like I was like okay
I was surprised when she asked me I was
like oh yeah did you help her write the
song Stewie did you help her with some
of the pen no no she wrote the whole
song you wrote everything
obviously help me obviously I mean yeah
some of it came from more I'm like
giving him ideas of where to go I'm more
just an engineering type no a r type
just like you know
I do music so you know I know where
people are what they want to hear so
it's just like I'm just coaching on that
but as far as the lyrics
[Music]
for lyrics
okay we got I I always try to figure out
the Dynamics of your love life blue
because it is very yeah from week to
week
I don't know what I'm saying I saw you
just where you just performed at the uh
the fight that that was a wild damn I
mean the whole night that was a wild
night but but but again like you perform
with Chris uh obviously you're you're
with your your girl right here
are you guys in a relationship or you
guys what's happening here like what's
the status of like what are you doing
depending on what week it is yeah I
think so
business it's like I'd rather get money
with somebody
then get money by myself not to play at
the point that I'm at and then some
people they want to get money by
theyself for me so it's like okay me and
Rock who's getting money together and
then you know I guess she felt the type
of way I mean I'm more in the music side
and I feel like she's more on the TV
side like she's more into this well you
guys have a team have you guys ever
showed you crazy no no but I'm saying I
only indulge in these ideas to benefit
the music for her you know I didn't do
it thinking like yeah that's that's
pretty Superstars reality TV you know I
do music so it's like okay I'm as these
opportunities come in I'm not okay yeah
we should do it it's gonna better your
music better your music more promotion
more promotion but
she kind of fell more in love with that
right so she kind of like made
relationships in that field in that lane
and you know that's not my Lane so right
I'm not gonna try to jump into that lane
to like so yeah so I just had to like
take a step back and let her pursue that
but Jaden she's doing we doing just
music like you know we're gonna take a
different route and it's gonna be a
different Lane it's gonna be a different
kind of a whole different how many songs
do you have today just the one just the
one yeah it's only been like two days I
don't say it's been quick because like
if you just decide you want to wrap a
month ago oh yeah yeah no we just put it
out like two days ago or so like Friday
I mean I mean how many songs do you have
that are just that you've recorded or is
this just that that was my first time
ever in the studio
I saw a DG's girl tweeted a line from it
yeah that was pretty good that was
really cool yeah yeah that was cool as
well all right Soldier Kayla everybody's
showing up out there baby if you guys go
on because you've been on double dates
with DG and Krishan and if you guys go
on a double date she's got to be like
I'm Little Mermaid what am I doing at
this bowling alley with blueface and his
roster I mean I don't know roster I
don't know
mermaid I don't know their relationship
status so like no but I don't even see
um lessons are learned you know from
from everything from everything so I
wouldn't even we wouldn't even insist on
that you know I was gonna tell you I was
gonna ask you this man for me you you've
obviously what are the lessons you've
learned from just a lot of the because
you've been through a lot blue uh we've
seen a lot of [__] pop off whether it's
uh by the way shout out to you uh for
going to my club she was puking in the
parking lot went viral but
um for you like are there any lessons
you've learned in terms of just trying
to maneuver this entertainment industry
while also being very forthcoming with
your personal life
yeah yeah I learned plenty of lessons
man even from
from like everything I learned a lesson
from even to rock and the ddg and how
this [__] even from I just learned that
you know certain people
shouldn't meet you know and it'll
prevent everything type thing so
I've learned from every everything that
you got in mind about how how is this
going to work out how is this going to
work out I've learned from all of those
things and it's gonna work out because
I'm not even gonna entertain those those
Avenues right we're gonna focus on the
music coming up music
music videos out let's go to Runway
let's go to let's go to like right
like if we're not making no music Jayden
I gotta ask you yeah do you have to have
thick skin
to be with this guy absolutely I mean
not even just thick skin maybe more so
like understanding like it's a what's
the understanding that he just does
[Music]
like whatever he wants to do not even
just like that like he he's very I mean
it's not like he's saying oh I'm you're
just like my own like you know what I'm
saying he's in my ear tone you're my
only girl or like or even just the next
but she's not saying that to them so
it's kind of like there's no coverage
it's kind of like I mean either deal
with it or deal with it like this is
what it is you can either accept the
circumstances I mean yeah I mean I'm not
gonna I'm not the type of [__] that's
gonna sit and Harper accept everything
though yeah no obviously we have I I get
on his ass about a lot of [__] don't get
that Twisted at all but I just I'm not
gonna sit and harp on
about something that I can't change or I
was gonna say like because you guys were
out a lot together and then uh you had
to go perform with you had to go perform
at the zoo's thing right so is that
something that you're yeah I understand
you got to go get get your business
right right for Sean yeah I mean I mean
it that was something that was also pre
no for sure that's already pre-scheduled
schedules so I mean I also give you
happy I couldn't I couldn't really say I
couldn't like what could what can I say
for real that's not she don't and that's
also not my Lane so I'm over here that's
over there right I'm going to make some
money I'm gonna tell her like yo I'm not
gonna make this money I don't know what
how you keep how you feel about it like
I'm bringing it back right so I mean I
don't know how mad I could be well I was
gonna ask you Jaden because obviously uh
do you have any relationship or have you
ever had any sort of conversations that
were peaceful with Christian because you
guys are gonna I have half siblings uh
no I don't think we've ever had no
peaceful nothing peaceful no I think
it's always the time no it's not even a
well it's not like I don't know what
he's talking about but
are you interested I'm not interested in
that at all I'm not I'm not interested
in that at all I kind of stay they would
never cross paths I just kind of I mean
I think this is like you obviously
you're gonna have a there could be half
brothers that's kind of that's kind of
more so like his dictation because like
he knows how I am with my kids that's
what it is not changing for because you
went and did that it's not changing what
I say is what I'm going with my kids I
don't know about like would you be
opposed to your kids meeting
you know his baby you know I mean maybe
under his care or my care just not that
person's just not happening but I mean I
can't really that's kind of that would
kind of be evil of me to like be like
they can never meet like I don't I I've
never had to have like a half sibling
with somebody that my mom didn't like or
something so I don't really know but
you've never had to go today yeah so I
mean but I also don't want to be the
evil Mom that's like you can't see them
like I mean he went and did that it's
like as long as he still goes with what
I am comfortable with I mean what can I
I can't really yeah like I don't really
there's not much I can do for sure you
know what I'm saying like I'm just being
real like that's just it's just like a
pretty reasonable human being I mean you
know like don't cross me but like yeah
this might annoy me like there's things
that I don't want to have to deal with
obviously that was like disappointing
but I don't I can't like sit and change
it so I'm not gonna be the evil one like
no and make it hard for him and make him
want to like do [__] that I wouldn't
like so I mean if I have to if I can
pick and choose I'll do that like do you
have any uh blue face tattoos
yeah I have uh the one on my ass and
then I have his initials right here but
you got this one too oh yeah and I have
this one you guys yeah it's a matching
tat right yeah I have this one this one
and then the one on my ass what's the
one on your asset it's just his uh
Jonathan Porter on it no you got the
[__] government
license plate that's interesting
yeah the last time I did an interview
with this guy my table got [__] up
every time
[Music]
no I respect I see that no um I was
gonna say uh For You Blue uh tell me
what's the update with your legal
situation because we've all I mean look
we've been hearing about what happened
you obviously got out quick guys
I'm on house arrest um
hopefully my next court date I could be
off house arrest if we can come to an
agreement and you know come to an
understanding and
you know
um now is the origin of all this stuff
that whatever happened at that strip
club no so I got to attempt to murder
case and that's because it's all in
Vegas yeah yeah it's on Vegas so I got
to attempt to murder case
and then um
maybe like a couple days before my court
date I came out here for my court date
and then I had got into something at
this casino
where rock hit this girl and then I had
to like you know play defense and you
know it just got got carried away and
then so because of that incident they
put me on house arrest and tell me I
gotta stay here wow
so all the all the the big the big the
attempted murder thing that's unresolved
yeah that's unresolved well I was still
dealing with I was still fighting and
going to court you know but once I went
to court for that case they [__]
booked me for that case like they put
like a weird warrant like the day of
right okay he's coming to court here
because like technically he like did
didn't wasn't doing what they asked of
him to do the few days before so I was
gonna take so like when you got picked
up a couple weeks ago what was was it a
probation violation no it was for the
for the [__] at the casino for that but
he came out here for that but he
probably should have just came up okay
at the casino
so the next court date they like they
put a warrant that day yeah right
because what I did wasn't enough for
them to like Grant a real warrant go to
California and get me for me right right
right right right have you decided uh
whenever this all gets resolved you're
gonna just leave Vegas alone hell yeah
just go to the Morongo bro it's like
never need to come it's like if you want
a gamble just go to Paul yeah that's
what I said all right I like bombs Rings
like every time you're in Vegas it's
just bad I only want to gamble no more I
just want to sit at home and make money
I don't want to go outside I want to go
to no bar no club or nothing I just want
to sit at home yo I mean
I've been um
I mean you dropped the record where you
were in the jet ski in the pool was it
called smile they have been having okay
um
how I mean you don't seem too focused on
putting out like a new album or anything
I mean you're just dropping here and
there but I don't know I'm just
like I said at this point in my career I
want to get money with my
significant other right you know that's
what I want to do I don't want to get my
significant other
um
yeah yeah others you know whoever wants
to be definitely my care you know like I
said I did it for myself already yeah so
it's like I did it for myself I did it
for rock now I can do it it's like I'm
just reassuring myself you know yeah as
time's going on
um
I just saw recently maybe two days ago
she had a spill Krishan had a spill
she's pregnant with you with your child
she had to spill at the club she found
out she fell in it
um hey man I don't know I was just gonna
say that personally I don't think she
should be in the club this late in the
game I don't think she I thought she was
rolling up on gorilla it's not about the
money it's not about now she just kind
of she just kind of lost in the
the hype of social media well I was
gonna say obviously you're she's
carrying your child that's your that's
your child right so how worried are you
about the safety of the womb the safety
of them I can't I can't worry until this
is it's on my plate you know right in
her belly when she has it I hope she
watches it wises up and like realize
that every penny is not worth
are you trying safety like like what's
the do you have you even put your mind
around the custody situation no no no
I'm gonna let her be a mom I'm Gonna
Hurt yeah try to be a mom and let her do
her best at it and then if she doesn't
succeed then I'll step in but
it's hard to push the baby all right it
hurts
more than that it hurts you spent nine
months with a baby in you and then you
push it out it hurts it's like kind of
yo yo the balls in your court I feel
like I mean the balls in whoever's
carrying the court I mean whoever is
carrying it from day one though like I'm
saying you as a mother you carrying it
you nurturing it when you pushing it out
you throw another story a lot of the
work you guys have two kids together too
yeah a boy and a girl and I've seen the
whole process it's a lot of work it
looks very painful and if you're going
through that you you gotta you gotta be
down for that you know yeah I was gonna
say like if it gets to the point where
you're like I got I gotta take care of
the kids oh yeah I'm gonna do what I
have to do but
I'm gonna let her be a mom are you
babysitting
I'm not babysitting I'm not babysitting
no she's not babysitting but yeah
I don't know she's responsible yeah I'm
responsible for what like in life yeah
yes I'm a responsible human being
absolutely but I I mean I'm not a
babysitter either
I I think that is something that they or
he needs to figure out I don't know I
don't really have no I'm not a good
figure I don't really have to say so
that's the least of my words I'm hoping
that she does a good job and once it
comes out she changed her state of mind
she still signed to you
know because she's kind of like your
artist the way I see it is when you
start doing business without me it's
none of my business you know what I mean
so that's a bar it's at that point like
you want to do business without me okay
it's none of my business I'm not using
that one I'm not gonna fight with you
I'm definitely using that I'm not gonna
go call these people argue with nobody
no no no I'ma just go find some other
business right okay so when you hit like
okay is this is this obviously you guys
have genuine love for each other she's
your your day one you guys have two
children together right but how much of
this also is business
because you're putting music out on me
here yeah
oh
it's all it's it's all business makes me
love me I think that I'm like a good
listener yeah like like I feel like I'm
a good listener like as far as like when
it comes to that side like he couldn't
tell me how to like change diaper or
something like that you're not just stay
in your lane but like as far as this I'm
like kind of like I want you to teach me
like I genuinely want to know like I
don't you know I don't know how to move
properly as far as stuff like I will
listen and I'll be like okay you know
because actually
I'm gonna tell a story about you okay
okay so so he got locked up the day of
my music video oh so so the day yeah he
was supposed to go to court meet me at
my music video and I was supposed to be
in the video yeah so um so
when that when he called me was like I'm
not gonna make it just make it lit do
what you got to do and I'm just kind of
like now you got to figure it out so
well I've never I've never done a music
video I don't even know if I I don't
even know if I've ever been to one of
his music videos from like to even like
watch see how it's supposed to be done
right like or how he talks to people or
moves
yeah but it was just me you and the
camera guy it wasn't kind of like it
wasn't a really like a production with
like several people and like girls like
and just like having to coordinate like
you know what I mean like so I just kind
of was like oh [__] but I felt like
I really didn't have a choice like make
it lit okay say less I'll make it lit so
then I showed up we actually I couldn't
even get to the house yet until I had to
message the people get into the house
because they didn't know what the [__]
was going on he wasn't answering the
phone it wasn't like I could be like
look this is what happened
I couldn't say that like that would have
looked so bad right so then I just kind
of was like look I just said he was on a
flight he got delayed everybody type
[__] so yeah so type [__] so that's such
an easy excuse to get out of everything
right they're like [__] it it's okay I
can't make it I got Coke bro like you
know so they they fell for it and I just
let them know like oh I'm gonna make
sure everything's straight so there's
like okay whatever so we go in there I
make sure it's all lit and I don't even
know what the point was but I was just
saying like he wanted me to make a shirt
happen so it happened from jail gave her
a couple appointments yeah so I just
kind of was like okay let me do that and
then um there were certain things that
he was talking to me about prior to
shooting the video like oh we should do
this or we should do that so I made sure
to incorporate that you know so I'm
listening to everything he's saying
whether it's today and if we use it next
week like I'm still listening I wanna I
generally want to know right like I want
to learn like I don't know it seems like
you're kind of like a a big part of like
Zeus Network success and I can't imagine
that like their most successful show
being your guys's show they wouldn't
want to continue that if they wanted you
to be like was It season three now or
two if they were like hey
out of here let's get Jaden in here and
let's run a new season
of
Crazy in Love no I don't think we will
do it I don't think that it should be I
want more music for her I'm just saying
I mean I think that if the bag might be
right oh I mean if the bag is ready but
I think no no no no no I think that
anything should be you not like we're
not saying no to no money but
we also got a vision you know and we
don't want to give
like when we Google her name you want
the music to pop up right to say
American rapper I don't want to say
realities
personality model Super Love and Hip I
don't want to say nude I want to say
rapper so that's because that's what I
mean that's the that's the business I'm
in right
I you know I did the only fast thing and
uh great but that's still under my
control I think you're more than like
music I think you're like that's where
my expertise is at but I think you're
also like you've mastered the internet
bro like yeah yeah like for music for
music and client reasons though so it's
like music incline but also just I just
think people are interested in you now
man
yeah me personally you're a figure man
like people just like what's going on my
son's magic I told him I don't know why
he's nine I totally my son literally
said you're gonna go interview blueface
tell him I'm mad at him I said why he's
like he broke rashawn's heart I said
what the [__] he's nine years old I
totally agree I totally agree but for me
passing something to somebody has got to
be music because that's like my
expertise you know I think you have a
lot of other expertise I do you wear
again you wear a lot of different hats
bro I blew up in a year like you blew up
quick off pure strictly my musically
incline
I made everything about music in Arizona
is the first time you brought the mop
out on stage bro my boy reposted he's
like this is the first I'm like I'm just
gonna that seems like it was six months
ago but it was like four or five years
ago nah I'm better with Artistry bro
Music is More on my Lane like of course
I can do anything now because I
succeeded at music but I took the music
to to get anywhere for me okay so me
doing that with her that's what I'm
gonna put I don't want to push
anything else uh so you're like all in
are you ten toes in because I I mean
this I've been I've actually been I'm
busy like prior to because all the
relationships I had she never [__] off
never did know like okay I don't know
what that means
like oh that's what he does on fact off
is like oh he's with this [__] let me
go be with this [__] okay
let me get even with you yeah like I'm
not really like that type of person
period yeah he holds the higher standard
for herself so me noticing that for a
long period of time okay yeah I could
give you the game I could ask you this
because you've been dealing with him
before we knew who he was okay
he has said some things in regards to
his other relationships he's been in
that make me think he's a little
Jealous Guy
would you say Blue's a jealous man
um yeah I would I I would I definitely
would because there are certain things
he gets mad about and I'd be like I
guess but I see what you're saying yeah
like you know what I mean like wasn't
like that but I see what you're saying
like you know I think he's territorial
right but as as a lot but as [__] I am
too like what you mean I don't like that
like more territorial like why who is
that in your video on the corner on the
left hand you know what I mean like if
you're a jealous territorial person I
might argue you don't think I am because
just because y'all don't see it it
doesn't mean
all right but listen no no no
she she's just territorial but she's
she's understanding like she's just more
mature you know it's not like she's not
gonna she's not gonna I mean I'm not
gonna go like she's not like
compromise herself to get even with me
or yeah to prove a point to me yeah like
she's more like just sane you know so
what you're saying is she would not
steal your Range Rover driving across
the country after writing stuff with her
own blood on the wall hell no okay
that's like I'm just curious when you
saw that that happened what is going
through your mind are you like my kids
are never going over there again
I said
what's the craziest [__] ever
um honestly I don't know I thought it
was kind of weird
um just because it was like the day
before Valentine's Day so it kind of
seemed like is everyone okay I don't
know I just don't really pay no mind to
that [__] attention I just don't
really like give into like the like woes
me type of situations like I just don't
care
so I kind of just treat it like a it's
another one of those shoes I mean I just
don't I'm just not gonna harp on stuff
that's like one one it's out of my
control two I don't give a [__] and
three has nothing to do with me like I
don't know I'm just don't Jaden I'm
curious
um obviously we know you as
his baby mama right
I mean obviously I'm sure he takes care
of his kids but prior to you being uh
starting this musical career or do you
have like a gig do you work like what's
your what do you what what are you doing
I had to work one day no
um I used to whoa before he did this I
used to work but yeah that's real tell
them no give me the real no he ever
since he when he got on and I had to
work which is you know God said I I
don't know I'm not ungrateful I'm not
ungrateful but I'm doing it for her to
you so you've never had to work yeah
since he blew up no oh wow not a second
not a day I don't have to there were
certain things I did just because I was
like yeah I want to do that or I want to
start this or I want to start that I did
a skin thing um that was I was doing a
whole like skin care uh treatment room
before I had my second kid okay but
after that one I kind of was like oh my
God two kids is crazy
that was something I kind of like yeah
like he wanted me to find something that
I like to do right right I don't mind
paying for you but like what do you want
to do
[Music]
I wanted to be a boss or something and I
and I just knew that if I couldn't be a
boss or something until like I was
skilled in it myself you know what I
mean because how am I going to tell
someone to do something and I don't know
how to do it I went to esthetician
school I funded a paperwork fire yeah
and then so you can do uh some facial I
can wax I can do all that yeah her own
parlor she was hiring people I [__]
with it but I don't think it was like
her dry I think it was just I wanted to
be a boss but I wanted like then I
wanted someone to like micromanage that
like tell me what everyone's doing you
know what I mean I wanted to get to that
point and I was almost to that point and
then I got pregnant again and then I had
the second baby and it kind of it
definitely slowed me down you know
um because I just I couldn't keep up
keep up with everything like and it was
it was about like 30 minutes away from
where I was at so I was just like
who can keep up with me and then whoever
was there ended up doing some weird [__]
to me I had to kick her out like yeah I
just drove by your uh
defunct restaurant yeah
yeah yeah was your mom running out they
just fixed the the windows and [__] my
mom was running it I mean that's
probably the problem huh
no I'm always running it and we just
kind of fell out and then I mean we've
seen yes he's like kinda like I just
fell off but I partnered with somebody
else
um you should put one in her Hood over
there in the valley and make it like
Ceviche bruh like you know the Mexicans
bro I'm trying to go Seafood boy around
you know what the bag you know like they
charge you like traveling yeah like crab
legs and corn and potatoes
crab legs for him
uh yeah dude you have a really
tumultuous relationship with your mom I
think I said that word wrong by the way
um but is there any repair in that
because shit's gotten super
my mama's far gone brother
I feel like when people get around me
they just like get poisoned by like
clouds fans and followers and attention
and then it's like I'm not gonna fight
with you about it I'm not gonna call you
and be like hey why did you do this why
did you do that I'm gonna just be like
the more I see you going your way imma
go my way you've been around this mom a
long time a long time do you kind of see
the night and day of it because I think
that
I think that honestly I think that she
doesn't take the internet as seriously
that it is like she'll like post
something and then not think it's that
serious but then it is that and then
it's everywhere you know what I mean and
like because it's a reflection and she's
a she's a Leo so I kind of I have like I
want to say three or four Leos in my
life so I know that they like they can
get angry or they'll want to say
something and then they'll say it and
then be like that was crazy was when she
talked about the size of your manhood I
was like this should not
[Music]
I think she said it in a way that she
didn't
people
dissect and take things in a way
different way that you like he could
post something right now and it'll be so
not like that they'll dissect it slow it
down who's in the back what's on the
counter that's the type of that's where
we live at though that's the generation
right now like they want to find
something wrong so she she is giving
them everything she is crazy she is all
that we but you like that's who she's
always been she's always been did you
still get to see the kids yeah she does
I do that I handle that more so than him
he doesn't I don't listen
I don't want to be in charge of no kids
I don't want to be responsible
this is great no I will look listen wait
let me land the kids are fine
okay that's why she hasn't worked
because I know you know when I have kids
with people I I don't like
people
well I'm only gone exactly one
experience but yeah but when I had kids
with her I was always happy I was always
sure I was always like
I'm not a babysitter bro I'm a provider
a leader protector that's what a man is
to me somebody who's gonna provide lead
and protect that's all I know how to do
so you're not interested in like a day
with the kids at Disneyland just you
know definitely he could never do he
could definitely do that though that's
about it though maybe if they're maybe
if they're like like walking they can go
in the bathroom
no diapers no bottles none of that like
we all eat the same thing and stuff
maybe absolutely then he I I think he
could yeah like I'll get you a corn dog
but diaper bag formula he is so nice I
gotta get out there and get it bro yeah
okay he's still not doing it if I'm if
I'm in the Gerber if I'm smoking I'm a
baby how am I making any money for the
baby so you're not doing the airplane
how much it cost to raise a baby it is
you gotta raise them for 18 years
it costs about wait listen yeah I have
my kids it costs about it costs about
ten thousand dollars a month buddy
you're who are you I have grown children
there's 12 months in a year that's 120
000.
ten thousand dollars a month it costs
ten thousand dollars I mean
I know it costs for your baby to have a
room a bed
a school a ride to school food to eat at
school it costs ten thousand dollars a
month
my kids living well
hey I every every kid should live well I
liked it I liked it I should live well
depending on what happens with this kid
that you're expecting we might want to
walk back that figure a little to maybe
like three thousand dollars a month in
case they come at you for child support
no I'm not worried about that
I'm not worried about you know I'm not
worried about that because
I've made her good enough to use her
she's good she can use her name anywhere
and get anything she she wants she
doesn't need you know
so I'm not making her dependent of me I
didn't for you you're not interested in
babysitting I can't bro I'm a provide
lead and protect and babysit
I mean it's it's possible
care for one two days maybe even three
days
do you think
because I think that like
there's certain moments in your kid's
life that are more influential than
others 100 and also there's just stuff
that like you know you're only gonna be
around for once 100
so make sure you're there yeah
so you're so you're gonna be around for
once right yeah I just mean there's like
certain moments in every kid's life yeah
you're gonna be around for once right so
just be there are you gonna take the
kids to what's the hard part about that
let's say your son starts playing
basketball you're taking my son plays
football he's been to football practice
football play basketball he's been there
he's been there I mean you're teaching
my son goes to school I'll take him you
know I can't take them every day but at
least
three to four days out of the week I'm
gonna attempt to that's amazing
I'm not a Debbie but I'm not like I
think it's clear you're not a deadbeat
yeah no definitely not absolutely not of
course not because if you're a deadbeat
I have to leave provide and protect well
you can't leave for Value protect and
be there every when you wake up when you
go to sleep when you eat lunch when he
did you feel me something you got to go
to work even if you work a nine to five
and you have a kid
eight hours of the day you're not with
the kid you're working Gator what would
be for you his biggest strength as a
father and something you'd like to see
him improve on yeah
hmm okay great question
um
strength is that
I think that everyone thinks that he's
not around but he is around we don't we
live in the same general area he's
around multiple times a week obviously
now this is one mile for me he's
obviously on house arrest now but you
know what I'm saying we've already made
the effort to do that I don't he's not
an absent dad so that's not his weakness
well he could improve on would maybe be
like disciplining I don't think that I
think that I'm more the like I have to
you got to lay the hair yeah because he
wants everything yeah and he wants to
come around yeah like he's like they are
presents that I have we
let's get 70 wings like you want to jump
off the roof let's jump off the route
like he's that but I think that as far
as disciplining he could help me a
little more because I think that our son
is getting to the age where it's kind of
like I don't have to listen to Mom he's
six oh yeah he's getting there he's like
he's kind of like I don't have to listen
to him he's been a kid though it's not
like he's yeah but like I can't even
give him a cuss like it's not like he's
doing belligerent things yeah it's more
like he's he won't listen he's finding
out his controls you feel me it's like
when you get when you're with your mom
all day because obviously I'm dealing
with this
if you're jumping off uh she's gonna be
one in August so it's kind of like I'm
dealing with her I don't he's like I'm
gonna jump off the bed okay great jump
off the bed I'm dealing I'm changing a
dirty diaper like great and then he'll
jump off the bed but also do three back
flips and then it's like I didn't tell
you to do that you know what I mean like
I didn't tell you to do that so why are
we doing nothing out of the ordinary
he's being sick but I need him to be
like I need you to I need you to listen
to Mom unplug the PlayStation yes yes
because sometimes he'll I'll be like
clean your room take a shower then you
can play Playstation no you gotta take
that [__] no he'll empty the
whole Toy Box like
I'm not gleaning [__] I'm not taking a
shower none of that I'm gonna just play
Playstation why would you do that it's
hard for me to like be mean to him
that's what I mean like sometimes she be
doing overboard though it's like she'd
be just tripping off
overboard it's having it's having like
he like can I get a snack no you can't
get no [__] snacks get the [__] down
no because yes
you let him have three snacks before
dinner why are you having three Sexes
you're not gonna eat dinner exactly and
then you're gonna stay up all night
again um Mexican black and Asian so this
is the thing about him a Mexican woman
if you don't eat dinner yeah
when you're knocked out Drool on the
pillow at 12 a.m and they're like I love
a sandwich I want something oh hell no
we already made dinner and I'd be like
damn why you like this because you be
asleep that's fine gotta stop the
interview to tell you about our family
at Odd Socks that's right the most
comfortable socks in the world ladies
and gentlemen uh go to
oddsocksofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg calf or bootleg both promo codes
work you'll save 20 out at checkout uh
20 off these are the odd Sox Basics all
right now you can get like a pack of all
black pack of all whites of course they
got all kind of crazy licenses WWE
Cheech and Chong they got Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles they got SpongeBob
SquarePants bruh look they got the
SpongeBob SquarePants Krabby Patty
draws
yeah now you don't want crabs but you do
want Mr crab's underwear because these
are fire all right so look go to
oddsocksofficial.com right now use that
promo code uh bootleg save 20 off a
checkout and uh yeah listen trust me
when I say most comfortable socks you'll
ever put on your [__] feet
and the most comfortable boxer briefs
what are we talking about man all right
oddsoxofficial.com promo code bootleg
save 20 off of checkout great gift and
and just treat yourself all right uh
also
got a shout out to our family a King
Palm now if you guys don't know about
King pong kingpong is all natural baby
yes all right we're talking about the
leader when it comes to uh tobacco-free
natural organic Leaf wraps if you're a
smoker a toader a straight west coaster
you know what I'm saying whatever you're
into King Palms they got it for you
what's great about
um these these are like one of the best
uh products that they sell now this is a
terpene infused tobacco-free leaf
and what's dope is you stuff your flour
into it
and then you press on the thingy you
know what I'm saying
and then you got flavor I'm going to
show you what it looks like when it's
stuffed
with some great tree from Jardin of
course
ah look at that
right get that thing stuffed up the tip
has got that flavor in it uh wherever
you're at man make sure you check out
the uh
um you know they got the smoke shops
they got those on lock they got
7-Elevens on lock we only smoking out of
King Palms baby you already know what it
is and if you go to
kingpoms.com
kingpom.com kingpom.com
and you use the promo code bootleg Kev
you will save 50 off at checkout half
off at checkout fifty percent off if you
go to kingpom.com and use that promo
code the promo code is down below go run
it up try some of these flavors too man
the peach pineapple the Strawberry
Shortcake they just got so much going on
there's also all kind of dope smoking
accessories you can get half off y'all
what are we talking about save 50 off
kingpom.com promo code below it's either
bootleg or bootleg have them these promo
codes got my head hurt try both of them
all right one of them get you 50 off God
damn it anyway let's get back to the
interview so you are you have black in
you besides yes yes okay because there
was this uh in the n-word and yeah and I
really don't like that I really hate it
actually now her grandfather's black
it's not even just that it's just like
if I'm 20 this 20 that 20 this I'm not
full it's not like I'm half this like
I'm a little bit of everything so it's
like I've seen a little bit of
everything like I can't always sit at
the table with all the black girls I
can't always hit the table all the
Mexican girls because they look at me
this or they look at me that I'm not
nephew this I'm not enough
I've been bullied by which like well
yeah cause you where you grew up I mean
I want to put your business out there
but where you grew up is a heavily Latin
Community right in the valley very much
yeah like in the San Fernando Valley
yeah so is that so did you go to high
school in the valley
or did you guys meet at the same school
or so I went to like five different high
schools of course you did I went to a
lot of different high schools in search
of like football you know so yeah
because I mean you would have played at
Fayetteville right yeah so whichever
school had like
a position for me and they had they had
a little bit recruitment coming in I
would [__] with them you know so I went
to
I went to belgia and Burbank to private
school I went to Valencia High School my
freshman year for like two months and
like by Santa Clarita yeah I went to
Valencia High School for two months left
went to Belgium for like a semester left
then I went to um Golden Valley I liked
the Golden Valley because it was more
diverse really diverse that's for sure
that's where I met her that's really
like where's that at it's in Santa
Clarita so it's a lot of um
it's just diverse yeah like all the
other bad kids get sensitive yeah I
almost bought a house out there yeah so
I went to Golden Valley right then I
went to I tried out for Washington High
School in the hood
not my hood but like just in the battery
um what other school what was it uh
narbon I was packed I tried it for nerd
bomb for long for a little bit
did I end up going to Arleta yeah
was that the prom that you guys
okay so I went to our leader he did all
those I went back to Golden Valley like
my senior year like I went to like five
different high schools every year every
semester I was at a different High
School like what how old were you when
you had your six-year-old
I was eight I had was just about to turn
18. so this was like senior year well I
had graduated and my birthday was later
that year so I graduated and that's
probably when like it happened when you
guys in the same grade or were you
younger I'm one year younger okay so
freshman was sophomore when you were
pregnant was he at no no Fayetteville
playing football no no it's like when he
just came back okay because he he left
right came back and then he was just
because we was kind of just ripping and
running and then I really wasn't on my
[__] like what's ripping and running
means
[Music]
no we was just doing our [__] we was
getting it how we could
well Hey listen how are y'all hitting
licks tell me please we was though I
believe it was I mean so look that's how
it started we met I was a sophomore
she's a freshman
uh
in PE class we headed off
then I started switching schools again
and we just stayed in contact she used
to come to my house every day after
school take the bus and everything
yeah she takes a hell of a bus the bus
is so crazy no but she he lived not
close it wasn't like it was crazy yeah
it was just like one up the hill like it
wasn't like 100 miles every day after
school we go to different schools and
[__] she got around every day after
school then go home when like it's
getting too late you know
all the way up until I graduated boom
I graduated I went to Fayetteville so
when I graduated went to Fayetteville
she was a senior
no I was taking two extra classes one in
the morning and one after school all the
seniors left at 12. no no I forgot about
that just so you can graduate wait look
no no to go to the school I didn't even
know cap I was behind on credits because
I would I would show up late or I would
just ditch right not show up because I
was just [__] around and so then my
senior year they were like you can
graduate obviously but if you want to
get a if you want to get to where he's
at you have to do this this and that
which was a class before everyone
started in a class after after so
everyone was coming at eight leaving at
12. I'm showing up at seven leaving at
one yeah so I was just like trying to
get into school I just wanted to I
wanted to be able to just get and go
because my mom I had a single mom I
wanted to get to the college I was at
just a video I had a single mom so I
wasn't like oh I I got someone that can
just sign this check off like and it'd
be cool like no I had a single mom
working a full-time job like what she
wasn't even paid for so this is like
really like a high school
you really love this guy now why she
love me the most
you live
please listen
only reason she left me I mean I always
broke up was because she left me
but why did I leave you he's he's
playing stupid okay look okay look
Christian got Jonathan's [__] title
right here and then she was like oh hell
no this she was pregnant at the time she
was like oh hell no I'm out of here [__]
she stole my car no it wasn't just that
it was so cat bro okay okay she got like
three tattoos it wasn't even just that
no no let me tell him
that's about you baby it is about me
explain okay because this is what
happens
don't do that okay so I left because I
was living at his house me and this uh
me and our son and then he had his mom
her husband oh he's all living in one
house but we was all like exchanging
days at the restaurant right when I had
my restaurant yeah I had a whole family
household we know
the same house good I'm telling him
there's no finishing stories okay so I'm
saying so we had the restaurant that me
and her got into it you and Mom yes okay
but me and her have been around each
other so long that it's like I've got
into it with my own birth mom that was
we was gonna get over it but I just
needed I needed to Stand My Ground
because that was crazy you know what I
mean so then I'm telling him and he's
not coming home every night this is not
the this is if you please if anyone's
out there thinking he's coming home
every night he's not okay he's so not
it doesn't matter how he makes it seem
like this he's not coming home
we got to get that third I gotta be I
gotta be bootlegs
he didn't sometimes to get bootleg out
there on the streets Kev you feel me um
all right go ahead anyway continue she
looks disgusted I'm disgusting this is
not even cute so so essentially he's not
coming home every night continue you get
into it anyway he's not coming home
every night and I'm pregnant I'm
pregnant as [__] throwing up in the
morning like oh you're not here in the
morning to hear me throw up right oh I'm
sorry I'm gonna do this and I already
have one and I don't even know what's
going on yeah and we just I just got
into it your mom she across the way
right
we got to figure out a living situation
for this or a restaurant situation for
this like when she coming this day I'm
coming that day what are we doing
because that was so not happening so
then you leave them so then I'm like you
don't come home in the next 30 minutes
I'm out I already have my bag sitting at
the end of the bed like this and you had
the clock running already I said you're
not here in the next 30 minutes I'm out
no he was out he I don't even think he
was away it was like seven it was so
early because I was like my mind is sad
asleep all night I said Christian at the
time honestly I don't know because
uh like I don't I don't know it could
have been anybody because she might have
not been around well he did bring up the
tattoos I gotta ask you from somebody
who you guys are high school sweethearts
you have two children together yeah you
see Christian she obviously blows up
she's a personality but she gets
you're okay your son's father tattooed
on her neck so all that happened while I
was pregnant so it kind of to me was
like oh y'all playing with me like and
and your your hormones are going crazy
well that's why I left him to begin with
this because so I was pregnant he's not
coming home he's acting a fool he's not
doing the most so I just left I'm just
going through a lot I took his car I
took his car and I just went to my mom's
what you gonna do now right now I'm
saying this this is and that now what
he's like oh you're crazy whatever we're
gonna have our gender reveal go to the
gender reveal it's not happening the way
it was supposed to happen like no so
look let me let okay let me chime in no
okay so when she leave me I'm like come
back you know please come back I tell
her for like a week I probably that
whole a week she's been gone I probably
hit her like three times like come on
come back you ain't gotta do this right
all right
so then right that's how I got stuck
with rock cause I'm all right you come
uh you in the game now you're in the
game now [__] come on my [__] left me
you're in the game come on like you're
in you're in I'm a high school I'm a
high school football coach you feel me
yeah that's how I'm out here coaching
Mighty Mites I mean junior [__] I'm
trying to find
okay can we take a shot everyone like
yeah
Cheers Cheers Cheers Cheers come on babe
cheers I'm not drinking this oh wait we
got to plug this in here okay you don't
need a drink let me help you out here
all right are we cheering Cheers Cheers
guys so that soda by the way guys he has
orange soda in the cup so boom I'm like
all right she left me like chicken she
like on her own [__] I'm gonna get my
own place I wanted to be in my name I'm
going to pay because you was playing
around baby I'll help you
she was like
my name is on the lease mommy got her
piece I was like damn that's okay she
showed you up no but you know what you
you know you know he was like all right
Rock You In the game come on okay
okay let's be let me let me I have to
take a stance here okay go ahead
somebody who has children
I can listen a pregnant woman yeah no I
know they get I was four months pregnant
listen you're going through a lunatic he
saw what I was pregnant than that no it
was four months pregnant we just found
out what it was but what was it I was
gonna say Obviously in like professional
I'm a lunatic you're out doing what
you're doing there's this girl getting
Jonathan's [__] attack exactly
and she's carrying your child and she
has your other kid and your mom and he
said oh I mean I didn't do that like
he's like the day one
and so for me I'm watching all this and
just from like somebody who
is just not even not even looking after
somebody who knows you just looking at
I'm like okay obviously Christian Rock's
good for business yeah right that's what
it started out as though I never wanted
aspire to people she started getting the
tattoos on her own
listen after her first tattoos her first
tattoos I said I don't think you should
be doing this kind of appropriate it
makes you look like you know your
intimate and it's less business
and she just wasn't listening well I was
gonna say did it spiral out of control
so much that you guys were
publicly so associated with with each
other that it kind of was like a forced
because listen when you got like she got
on his blue Faces girl well when y'all
came to the studio last time I
interviewed both of you guys
um it was you could cut the tension
between y'all with a knife yeah no it's
kind of like it's kind of like
she got on his blueface's boyfriend
girlfriend I mean you wouldn't have a
boyfriend obviously
girlfriend but it's like
she kind of like
used that and then when it wasn't usable
she kind of used that and then when it
wasn't usable she kind of like all right
let me
let me let me go this way you know like
I said I'm not gonna fire you are you
hoping she gets the tattoos removed no I
mean I really don't care for me
personally tattoos are a part of the
time history you know trials and
tribulations and I feel like I'm a part
of her time his three Childs and
tribulation so
is there any more business for y'all to
do together
man I'm always interested in business
I'm always open to business but like I
said earlier once you do business
without me it's none of my business and
the relationship aspect of YouTube is
done
I mean she has my if she has my child
I'm gonna no no you guys are gonna have
a relationship I just mean in terms of
like you guys being intimate you guys
being you know any sort of uh
are you are you done clapping Christian
Rock's cheeks at this point in your life
personally
I don't think that
I think that she she might need to be
humbled something might need to occur
for her to
realize like hey
all these people are all year round
because of who I am today and not who I
was three years ago
and it's just a humbling experience you
know like I just like I I saw I saw
Chicago the club and I was just like
damn like well that was recently yes
yeah like two days ago
like hey they keep deleting my Ig like
here's 10 grand go sit down like I don't
want to trust me to get miscarriage
trust me I will pay for her to sit down
but
she's into the attention she likes
people walking up to her she likes the
camera she likes the attention so it's
like I can't fight with her on that you
feel me like if you get more of a
feeling of people saying hey hey then
you get off being home and and enjoying
having a home to be at and and having
you know your own then I'm not gonna
fight with you on that bro because
Jayden I'm curious
a rough pregnancy in terms of him not
being around or maybe you just kind of
being
in in some some dramatic times do you
empathy empathize with her at all with
what she's going through with her
pregnancy
no I mean
I mean this is about this baby this
one's about me though yeah I don't
sympathize about that at all because my
pregnancy was very
traumatic
um
I don't know it was very traumatic not
even just because of that situation
period but like I had to disconnect from
someone that I didn't plan like this was
planned this was planned so it was kind
of like this is weird to me and all that
is weird to me so it was kind of like oh
that's lame and then it was very public
while I was pregnant so it was kind of
like that's even more lame like yeah so
I don't have no sympathies because and
I'm not going into nothing and God knows
that I'm not going into nothing like oh
this is why I'm doing this and this is
why I'm doing that not at all like
I'm doing what God is handing me but I
don't have no sympathy as to to nobody
that like spitefully did [__] to me like
I don't have no sympathy towards that
and then I mean I feel like and that's
just what it is people like rock back
their home so she don't mind wrecking
her home I'm not wrecking nothing it's
you're not even like was the rock thing
did it really get dropped at it because
obviously there was the only fans thing
right
um where he had the house Blue's house
which was successful for you yeah he had
a bunch of chicks coming out of the
Woodworks
um you kind of revolutionized the only
fans thing for dudes yeah you know
um but for you
you're looking at that as I mean so he's
it's work so okay someone's coming in
yeah so like the first season to me was
kind of like oh you did not say he was
doing this this and that but now you're
doing this this and that so that's kind
of what sparks the whole initial like
what the [__] like but now I'm kind of
like okay I see what you're doing I see
what you're on
whatever but at first it was not like
that I was gonna say like and then
there's the there's a Christian thing
just get dropped like you're like wait
this is a thing like I've been like were
you telling her like don't worry about
her okay no no let me tell you let me
tell you the exact story so I did blue
Girls Club season one
then probably two days
season one but he stayed he's not he's
gonna leave that okay it's two days of
season one
was the youngest at the time
she was actually younger than I was
anticipating like I only won the 21 and
up because everybody was drinking I
can't promote underage drinking
just slipped through the crack she was
like 20. so
and she she was just as raunchy as she
is now she was just his
like irritable as she is now so none of
the girls liked her they all picked on
her they uh right you know so I kind of
maybe showed her a little bit more
attention and care of just because I'm
like you know you're the youngest like
thug it out see it through right
but she's at home watching like oh no
you like her you care about her with the
Wham it's more that's more
so she pulls up the second day with her
friends to confront Christian runs out
hit something breaks her tooth
and so I'm not there at this time so I'm
not there to break anything up I come
back
um or no I was there but I was upstairs
when she confronted Christian so I
didn't see anything or or dictate
anything I come downstairs for Sean's
ran out already she's there my sister's
there I'm like bro what the [__] is
y'all doing I'm trying to run a whole
little thing here and you guys are
conflicting with the business helicopter
pull up it's a whole big old deal like
because Christian ran out butt naked she
probably went to a neighborhood yeah
late at night it just seemed bad so
I come downstairs because Sean's gone
she's there my sister's out there they
yeah I'm like what the [__] is y'all
doing I'm [__] up my business so I
started tripping on them they leave now
I'm worried about Christian
following day day after she comes back
her tooth is like
it's not out but it's loose I'm like oh
my [__] God I know my big mama and my
sister and I just pull up and [__] her
not they didn't even touch her she ran
upset but not yeah you didn't see what
happened yeah it seems like it's my
fault you know because I'm hosting this
thing and then people that I personally
deal with never pull it up
all right so now I'm feeling like a
disgusting human being because I'm like
damn this this 20 year old girl yeah you
don't think that you could have been
honest there was nothing to be it was
two days I just met the girl so don't
think I didn't I didn't even like I
didn't even like her anything about that
don't say you sleeping somewhere and
you're not
if I said you're saying because I wasn't
I wasn't yeah he should have been honest
from the jump because he was like I'm
not sleeping here I'm going home so
you're crazy
I started it I only had one camera man I
was unprepared I had eight girls One
camera man one camera man and about two
security guards right so after the first
day I'm like [__] this is I had to be
security guard I had to stay the night
there and she wasn't okay with that
she's like oh you didn't say you had to
stay tonight I mean is that not
validated okay I get it you know I'm
playing counselor to the youngest person
who's more who needs more attention and
more attentive right so she's at home
watching it I'm recording everything
everything's live everything's
documented I went home like oh no that's
the one you care about that's that I'm
like no she just hey there's nothing
like a female's intuition though because
she was right because what do you mean
like that's right she wasn't going on
she wasn't she said fast forward a
couple of years listen you wonder why
she wasn't right because if she would
have never done that
I don't think me and Christian would
even know each other to this day because
you felt bad because yeah I only felt
bad because my baby mother put up this
girl is not from California she's the
youngest girl there my sister is with
her you're probably also worried like
disco myself like it's just bad so now
I'm like damn they pull it up and your
tooth's missing okay now I have to
change your life I've changed your life
physically you'll never you'll never
grow that tooth back that tooth will
never come so that was day two day two
okay after day two well first of all how
many days in before you sleep with
question Rock for the first time I
didn't sleep with rock till like day
twenty day twenty because I knew she was
kind of jaded at daytime I know she was
kind of [__] with him freaked out in
her mind like she she wasn't she was the
way she is today she was like that then
she was just I think that there's this
rep that you believe oh yeah no no no
just back then because we see because
listen you've seen the pictures of her
when she's like that's high school young
and then they're like look at her now
this is with her that's her face to put
you their pictures when she was 16 17. I
don't like that I met her shot when she
was 20 right by then she had already
dropped out of college she had already
she messed up her knee from the tag show
so she wasn't athletically capable to
you know accomplish what she needed to
accomplish so that's why she was on my
show she was down and out she was like
looking for a way out
met her cool wasn't interested no
intention she comes up my with my sister
blood sister her and my blood sister
come chase her out of the house
hit her mouth miss her tooth now I'm
like what the [__]
do you regret that
I tell them to this day it's your fault
that Christian still exists to me it's a
very narcissistic thing to say it is
very wow because that's exactly because
you I know myself
I've never took any female Pastor let me
recant what I said it sounds like
because you you that could be your truth
you could be being genuine yeah right
but it's also like an easy thing to say
to be like oh it's really not because
you know this is your fault I've done
five seasons and I've never have done
anything with any of the women after
after the season
during the season during the season I
have to see I've never promoted promoted
these girls promoted them no but none of
them was able to go and get a show or
something like that so that's cap but me
and Christians
so that's cats what I'm saying
me and Christian have only been in
business because I I didn't you don't
still feel bad because you paid I don't
still feel bad you pay for the tooth and
it is what it is
do you think Blue's a narcissist I think
he has narcissist Tendencies right but I
don't think he's like a full-blown like
everything he does is with that intent
but there are some things he does where
I'm like I feel like okay now you're
trying to flip it on somebody else to
make yourself feel better I have a way
of acting out of emotion and
as a man once these actions are made we
don't get to just cover them up I mean
like I can't throw a temper tantrum in
here and throw a drink on you and slap
you and people be like well you did this
to her you did that to her if I did that
to you as a man you know they're gonna
hold me accountable right
right if I throw a drink on your sloppy
they're gonna say damn blue face
he didn't have to do that he didn't
deserve that but if she does it to you
they're gonna make up 101 excuses well I
think I think it it was a very
um abusive relationship because I think
I mean we saw when you guys were outside
of the was it the the spot on uh
you know and you were you were like
defending yourself yeah because I'm like
this listen Christian is an athlete so
if she's throwing hands on you bro like
I'm like what do you want me to do you
want me to get [__] assaulted like
and so for me I think it's nice because
I think that obviously you have illegal
[__] going on and I feel like at all
times
you were like a walking DV case waiting
to happen well because I feel like go
ahead go ahead I'm sorry I just feel
like that he's so
he's very calm so it's kind of like it's
kind of like no he's really calm so it's
kind of like to spark that you gotta be
like Off Your Rocker I'm like the Hulk
so it's kind of like you piss him off
you you sit down hit that switch over
and then you're at home no no it's like
you you normally you push people away
like no don't do it I don't want to turn
into this on you I don't want to do this
I don't do this but you keep okay once
the Hulk is awake [__] you can't once
the kill switch is flipped man I feel
you you can't tap rub my back bro I'm
gonna just like do some Hoka Mania [__]
and then once I do that different Hulk
there's Hulk Hogan I
think that you trigger I think everybody
triggers a different person than
somebody so it's kind of like
I let him be the star I don't really
kind of like I don't I'm not craving to
be the star I want him to be the star
well now you got to be the star yeah I
mean yeah that's great that's great but
I I wouldn't I wouldn't be even doing
being Stewie if it wasn't for him so
it's kind of like I wouldn't sit here
and be like I'm better than you and like
it doesn't even matter like I can go do
that like I wouldn't do that because
because let's say I'll go do a show
right now I'm still gonna like free my
BD like what you mean like I wouldn't I
shouldn't even be here without him for
real for sure but he told me to be here
so it was kind of like for sure
um I saw you had recently you got a BBL
right yeah was this in uh America or
you're going to teach it no I went to TJ
the second time so you've doubled up on
the BBL well I had the first one was uh
yeah
every time I got a kid I got a certain
uh I go to the dentist every time
because I don't have I don't have health
insurance because I'm an independent
contractor so when I go to get dental
work done I go to Tijuana
amazing doctors they're great and I the
first time I went to Beverly Hills the
second time after Journey
yeah after after our daughter is he
covering the cost in the BBL yeah I'm
not of course no the first you better
pay for this bro the first time she went
to Beverly Hills she was like they won
30 000. I said for what
she said just to take the fat out of my
stomach and put it in my ass I said
but we were very naive too thank you
they took advantage they were very they
find a better deal than that but I
didn't know about like TJ and then it's
not even that it's just like I think if
you go to Beverly Hills for anything
yeah it's gonna be overrated they're
hitting you upside the head because
they're gonna be like well Kylie was
here and yeah it's like go to Arizona so
I didn't agree with it but I was like
you know what for you [__] it if it'll
make you feel better about yourself [__]
thirty thousand do it 100 so the second
time we had another baby she was like
you know I found a better a place where
they could take out more fat right and
do more better banks for book right and
I got a tummy tuck and a BBL that was
probably about a month ago she's still
here no it was like two months
uh I got it in May
yeah so it's been like two months the
bbo essentially is I don't understand
what the tummy tuck is right because
that's kind of like um it's kind of like
if you have kids if you have and you
have that pouch it just never goes down
it just I can work out so much because I
was and it just it will never go away
because it's bad so the second time she
got out the arms of the stomach and then
they put it in your cheeks in my hips
well no my hips not my ass I just got in
my hips uh I just got I just got my hips
because I just wasn't trying to be OD
like right I don't really that's not my
goal is to be you know it's funny
look all right can we see what the
tattoo looks like of the Jonathan Porter
tattoo where is it is it how I don't I
mean I don't want you to like exposure
oh there it is oh yeah that's OG tat
right there that thing looks like it was
done in prison
yeah
I I think you'll you'll see some bbls
and they're they look terrible right
this this looks solid yeah good I mean
shout out to Mexico right it's a good
place definitely it looks a lot a lot
more like
it looks a lot more ratio ratio for sure
online sometimes they do they do find
where the angles to where I be like damn
it don't even look like that's why I say
like oh it don't even talk about like
diaper and all this weird [__] why isn't
actually Jaden like you
some listen there is a certain aspect of
the internet that rides hard for
Christian and automatically oh yeah
sorry so I don't really care yeah it's
like a pick a side thing so pick a side
then so my
thumbs up I mean like pick a side I
don't give a [__] because to me I'm not
in a competition I'm in my own thing no
traffic there ain't no traffic if you're
in your own lane you feel me so it's
kind of like I don't give a [__] so if
that's if you want to side with that
side with that because you already know
my [__] play in the club we going up
well I'm just curious like I'm sure
people like like you said like we've
seen memes about the Drewsky thing and
it's funny that's great well I think
it's something that you take it that way
because I think
we are in an aspect where everyone's
gonna come at you on the internet yeah
regardless I mean at first obviously it
was kind of like how do you deal with it
is it hard at first it was kind of like
ew like what do you mean like um Stewie
I'm just kidding on this I'm that like
ew right but but I think that I don't I
don't like come on now the thing is is
like I think with anything especially
like internet driven because again this
guy's a goat on the internet he is so
much so okay can we shut your guy's door
who sounds like he's in there having a
podcast shut the [__] up yeah we
recorded tiny all right shut the [__] up
she sounds like he's in there cussing
someone it's not like you having a
podcast [__]
that's right ladies and gentlemen it's
getting hot outside that means
I don't know what that means it's just
hot so I feel like when it's hot people
want to [__] more right so you know
fellas if you're dealing with erectile
dysfunction it happens to the best of us
I'm sure maybe you are old maybe you are
dealing with stress at work maybe you
don't want to sleep with the same lady
that you're married to over and over
need a little extra motivation to get
that thing stayed up you know what I
mean go to uhboochu.com use the promo
code bootleg and they'll send it
straight to your door three-month supply
of Bluetooth for free all right now
there's Bluetooth work yes it does
you're gonna get a free month supply to
be able to see for yourself blue
shoe.com promo code bootleg uh now if
you don't know what it is it is the same
active ingredient as Viagra and Cialis
but in a chewable form and you do not
have to go to a doctor's appointment all
right you do everything online you don't
have to go sit at a doctor's office and
talk to some old man in a lab coat about
your dick issues not necessary anymore
in 2023 all right so go to Bluetooth
sign up with that promo code bootleg get
a month supply for free let's get back
to the interviews no I was going to say
though like listen like bullying is real
like self-esteem is a real thing like it
out okay so the social media thing is a
real thing because I got a taste of it
when I was pregnant so it was kind of
like this [__] sucked for sure I can
only imagine because I really saw some
[__] I did not want to see when I was
pregnant like the whole time not like
start to finish like
you don't forget like because yeah the
internet will forget but it's you
personally will never ever ever like get
off you right like even if you if that
one person bring it up oh I'm gonna suck
you in your mouth my thing is is like we
all take in comments a certain way but
no matter what they might hear it
all that but I mean I don't
I come to like I watch him so I kind of
like okay so like because there's plenty
of things they say about him and it's
like oh that's so cat like it's so kept
to like where's point I'm like okay now
I know the internet is ridiculous are
you getting like um
hate DMs like crazy people saying hey
I've had like six Instagrams all her
Instagram every single one they delete
them they just flag you yep what
[__]
I don't even know I've made like six in
the last month
Rock Hive coming for you yeah
I think it's her personally but I think
no no it's her fan it's just a pick a
song she has a very heart like she has
like bro when we did that interview I
saw it and that just kind of gives like
what type of females was out there like
yeah so you're on that that's probably
why you don't like it and me personally
like if I don't agree with what you
doing or how you doing it I'm not going
like hype you up I'm gonna be the first
to be like nah you know
so that's why me and her kind of like
fell out like I don't agree with a lot
of things so it's like I can't co-sign
it I came back for it you at the club
pregnant eight months like falling off
it's just like bro I can't how can I
defend that like you feel me yeah I
don't care how much money they paying
you it's not worth it's not worth it
yeah make the money don't let it make
you like I don't care how much somebody
pays me I couldn't do nothing
homosexually feel me
how much how much weight of a 10 billion
dollars nothing bro if they gave me a
billion said hey yo kiss bootleg camera
[__] you wait a billion dollars you
wouldn't know I wouldn't kiss you that's
crazy I'm kissing you for a billion
that's what I'm saying like for a
billion dollars I'll kiss blue so this
is yeah that's the difference for a
billion dollars
[__] the principal it's 20 23 give me my
bill I don't know maybe because I don't
know I mean
I never hear from me again I understand
both sides I understand both sides I'll
never knock the hustle for me I've never
poked a shamrock on any type of contract
pause this one bro I've never put
Cristiano any type of contract any type
of paperwork I'm like it's not about
that I could have I could have had her
sign
her whole life away but that I don't
want that if I don't want your life do
you you're somebody who we don't ever
really get to see like the super
vulnerable side of do you get to do you
see some of the [__] that gets said
about you whether it's a misconception I
see I see everything but I'm saying do
you like
you're never gonna deal with it publicly
but does it ever get to you
yeah I mean I see everything it never
gets to me I just try to try to turn it
into money same thing I did with her
I didn't write her song but I
constructively oh they talking about
this I had this to you know they talking
about that I had that too this is more
you know if you can feel it you can feel
it if you can see it you can see it it's
just easier that way I was gonna ask you
we talked uh the last time me and you
talked and rock was here I think we we I
think
we just talked about the pregnancy
I feel like you're not the kind of guy
who's really built for marriage
I'm both for money
like I said the people I deal with I'm
gonna get money with them well at least
my [__] right my [__] like I want to
get money with her because I'm planning
for the future like I'm on house arrest
I go to jail
I want to be able to call you from jail
hey
exactly and if I notice you're a type of
person then like if I'm not there you
yeah yeah we can do this yeah yeah we
can do that we can do that it's gonna
rub me the wrong way because like why
are you saying yes to this and we
haven't
are you at all we haven't said you're
too worried about because I don't want
to I get into the details of anything
that happened but I mean with anything
that is legal it could go either way
right so you kind of have to prepare for
the worst oh I'm worried I'm 100 worried
and that's why I'm you know I don't
usually worry about it I'm giving her
the torch I'm putting the ball in her
court so that way
like hey blue they want to do this what
do you think I should do before she say
Yes No Maybe So she gonna if that ends
up happening are you letting her take
control yeah 100 somebody else you gotta
trust you I mean I feel like I'm gonna
be in control
oh
is your sister still I I don't know
what's going on with your sister is she
with your mom was like because yeah I
mean they all got that thing going on
yeah I can't you know anything I don't
got control over I don't
I'm not gonna
call try to I know all right do that
right cause I could do this with anybody
bro
what she's like what do you mean not
dude that's weird but I'm saying I can
make anybody popular
stand next hey that's true stand next
yeah go ahead and make them popular all
you got to do is stand next to me you're
gonna be you're gonna be lit right
you're right but I'm gonna no because
I'm gonna boothy as [__] no that's still
going to be look like if he grabbed some
chick from Chipotle tomorrow and put his
hand around her this is my new chick
she's on so
um Stewie is out
actually going crazy Milk Music joke
real LLC
real company feels like a joke feels
like the kind of thing blue face would
be like man I'm on house arrest my my
girl just dropped the record we about to
just I don't know we're about to have
this moment MILF music you only can get
signed if you have a child no ain't [__]
funny about it it's real business and
it's real it's really going on man
um I agree are you gonna just keep
dropping singles
um I think I could definitely I would
definitely go in there again
so to a studio yeah so yeah because I
definitely see myself doing that more
because I I liked how I felt which was
great but I liked how everyone is
reacting what's your first song even
better it's viral it is you have a lot
of improvement that needs to be done I
appreciate it yeah but I'm very grateful
it's your first song ever I mean I'm
very grateful you know because some
people release their song they got like
6 000 views I'm like um
that's his effect yeah absolutely and
that's why I said he's the star I'm kind
of like just like a accent like I don't
mind being accent I would rather him be
the star but hey you never know if he if
he got to go sit down you might have to
if you got to sit down and period so
that's the best part about it I'd rather
her be this time she'd rather than me be
the star so it's never like me thinking
for ourselves it's never like we gonna
compete with each other we never gonna
split the fans up and be on here like no
she's in my way she's cut she's in the
way of My Success and she's not gonna go
in there like no he's [__] blocking me
he's not he's hating him you know so
it's like we gotta
it's lit man
um the rules of your house arrest you
you have to stay in the house yeah yeah
okay
who don't realize you are yeah bracelet
on your wrist or on your your ankle
right there to court that is a massive
all right [__] can you shower
with that microwave on her yeah I can't
submerge it
yeah there's a pool in the back here you
can't swim he got to put his foot out oh
wow that's crazy time [__]
what yeah listen man we're gonna sit
right here with me she could be anywhere
else doing anything else but look I
think it's you guys obviously have a
very long history I didn't know you guys
were she trying to go join you in
Fayetteville when you're playing
football I mean I tried but he came back
before that so but I'm saying like I
think that I can't I can't I came back
for her before she came from why does it
say I think we see like very Snippets of
what you guys are yeah
I've had her on the radio show videos
she was on Big Boy yeah I mean in terms
of like just I I don't I heard having to
go to school an extra two hours a day
just to try to go see oh yeah you know
taking the bus every day like I got some
chick pregnant no yeah and now she's
around that's what I'm saying so whoever
I pick is I'm not picking no
was he always there no Scripts yeah
I gotta ask I was asking
you've been like this he might have been
more like discreet but I think now maybe
he just is not so much I've been like
this bootleg like I ain't changed since
I started it was that though it wasn't
like he wasn't like he just wasn't
just what he feels like he can't because
he just yeah I was not discreet before
because I was regular you know now I'm
taking care of households I'm bleeding
providing protection you're so cool now
I just feel like I'm a man
I mean you are you feel me and there's
not a lot out there you know from me to
you it's not a lot of men out there
who's gonna leave provide and protect
there was uh O3 Greedo before he went
went to jail because he knew he was
going on like you right he uh recorded
the thousands of records are you like I
don't see a studio setup
it'd be me ah yeah
but I had my time I had a great time but
this is your thing right we're like
again we're not operating on any fact
I'm just saying worst case scenario you
have to prepare for anything right you
have to go sit out like for what if that
even happens I every letter I sent her
is going to be a rap song I'm saying
though shouldn't you be recording a lot
no because then while you're sitting he
doesn't okay she could drop 13. because
he doesn't prepare
he's not a like oh in 10 years I want
you to drop this or in two two weeks I
want you to drop he doesn't prepare like
even today like y'all was coming he said
you got 30 minutes
I said I got 30 minutes hold the [__] up
I don't even gotta get this whole thing
together very last minute I don't even
got a [__] Christmas BET Awards I I
was like me and him but I'm saying
though like he doesn't prepare he just
does what he wants to do at that moment
so it's like well if I were to advise
you blue
you should be in this [__] just
cooking up verses bro
because because guess what if you if
something happens she can sell one of
these verses to somebody first what's
that gonna do for me she could say her
own version I understand it's better for
her than for me bro I think you should
be cooking I know this I cook all the
time oh my God I got at least
unreleased songs right now here's the
Guitar Center absolutely yeah I got at
least 50.
but I have no intent of dropping these
songs I don't know
the music thing you and ddg were
supposed to come out with an album I
heard a lot of the music and it was it
was it was delicious you guys are
battling each other yeah is it ever
coming out I hope so
um
the thing about artists is sometimes
they'll be on their own path day on
their own journey and it's hard to get
on the same Lane
because I look at you kind of
made it possible
not I don't want to say that because DG
is a talented kid no but yeah no but he
definitely started something will you
helped validate him as an artist and not
a YouTuber with moon marketing Calabasas
yeah absolutely that's the truth yeah I
think it would just be dope just because
I've heard the record y'all got I got
some [__] I like that back and forth
where they're battling because it's
crazy because they say that me and him
should go back and forth
which I think would be crazy but
I'm not really an artist type like I
[__] with people like for instance with
her I [__] with her so I mean she's
obviously what does that mean so it's
not about the music
it's not about the song that was just
that she just released it's not about
the the notoriety is trash you would
have won this card
but you know it would have never been
tried so listen can I just be honest
it's not not trash no it would never be
trash I would never wait wait
it's not not trash yeah no anything I
got to do with would not be so you think
it's fresh whether you think it's a fact
whether you think about it your song yes
if I'm being honest yeah out of ten yeah
we don't care out of ten we've heard
worse than what you buy what you say yes
this is your first song you've ever made
ever made we don't want to get we don't
want to get the first song I don't want
you to support it like it's like okay
okay I'll give you the critique right
now let's say I had no idea this was the
first song you ever made and I had no
idea that you were involved with him and
you were you came up to me and you said
hey I got a single I want to play and
you play me that song I would laugh at
you and it's it's I would say it's a
steaming pile of dog [__] if I'm being
honest so you would laugh inside I think
I think it's a horrible thing okay so
when it blow up and then when oh
the situation in the context of the
situation this is your first song you
ever recorded that's why I said context
is important but just on a song creative
basis
I personally think it's terrible I mean
but he's a man I'm a 36 year old
Caucasian who listens to [__] Pusha T
and Griselda and The Roots so this your
song is not for me
[Music]
and guess what when he started to get in
his bag
he came from thousands of miles
but when he went he wasn't in the room
when we're on video and I'm doing images
of the rappers and I was like you know
who's like the most improved rapper
blueface is getting off and I remember
he'd be like bro really and I'd be like
you I mean
I've given you flowers when you weren't
in the room on video where I'm like yo
blueface be saying the flyest illest
[__] and he's in a pocket because when
you first came out I had never you were
beat bro it's kind of like a thing that
people don't understand they don't agree
with you know and I want you to look at
me and just I I don't want to offend you
you're not offending me
the appeal of your record right now
is you are his baby mama absolutely
right he's decided to put you on right
and you made a song this is your first
song you ever made so this is very
important because most time People's
First songs that they've ever made never
get heard I know that's obviously I was
just telling her I was like you got 250
000 views in one day I'm like man if I
had that at this very moment your first
song being ever made if I'm judging it
on that scale it's it's cool I I get it
I gotta get my props I'm not mad at
Stewie I like the fact that you guys
went with the Stewie thing
like again it's not for me now you have
tons of improvement because you can't
rap
you're really bad at rapping but you're
gonna get better and for what you guys
are building
I'll it's working 250 000. like I need
you to understand doesn't matter what I
say it's about the market I mean
well who thinks
I think you're a sweetheart and I think
you have a great head on your shoulders
and I'm glad we had this conversation
and I'm glad people are going to be able
to kind of see more of who you are I
think you're you're rapping this is the
first song you've ever you just decided
you know what's crazy well listen let me
finish you just decided 30 days ago you
want to wrap it and that's correct so
that's why when I told you if you were
to come up to me and I had zero context
about your whole situation yeah now if
you're telling me 30 days ago I decided
I wanted to rap and a week ago we
recorded this song or two weeks ago we
shot I'm gonna say not hey not bad good
job no what what let me be honest good
job let me ask you this [__] full
time
for your first song not that okay let me
ask you this
would you say the same thing did you
make the same observation
I think rashawn's rocks music's [__]
god-awful
um so that's not what I'm asking I'm
saying would you have the same
observation I would in the same context
that I just told her because again I'm
not not sure like how long because you
did you convince her to make music yeah
same same exact process I think that
um the roll-up plays more than the music
yes and I think that it so what this is
what I tell people about music all the
time
the market will determine
what is good or not if people are
watching you you have people's attention
right so all you have to don't worry
about what old white dudes like me say
but yeah it doesn't matter
no who cares but here we go here we go
no no but no but who cares
I I gave you two opinions I gave you the
opinion that if I didn't know who you
were and you walked up to me and you
said hey uh I want you to play my song
on the radio can I play you a song and
you play me that song I gave you that
opinion which would be the full now and
then there's the opinion of I have the
full context of you just started rapping
this is your first song you've ever
recorded uh there's so much on the
contact side where I can be like well if
this is the first time you've ever
recorded a song you are a full-time
mother raising a one-year-old and a
six-year-old absolutely and 30 days ago
you decided to make a song yeah not bad
with the full context I am mad at you so
I got to give you both sides
okay I mean I don't I'm not mad about it
his opinion doesn't like make sure it's
not gonna make her break like this is
the thing you'll you have attention so
all that matters is what you do with the
attention okay right so I would tell you
this please if you're gonna do this rap
[__] the next record better be two or
three weeks away
for real
you gotta treat this [__] like a
full-time job you have to stay
consistent okay cool the Stewie video
dropped what's the next move what's the
next one let me start listening to beats
get ideas from him
cool we did a Stewie let's do this and
drop another one you know I think that
that's what I would tell you yeah but
look look that's what we already own
like I said I
I I have a lot of respect for you
because you are raising two kids and
you're literally a full-time Mom this is
what you do you raise children like are
dealing with your your six-year-old
you're [__] up his bedroom and not
listening and you recorded a song within
the last 30 days
knowing that I would say hey not bad
keep going
but I told you my opinion if you were
just to come up to me and I didn't know
the [__] you were I can appreciate it
I mean that's uh honestly personally
personally I feel like
even if somebody who came up to you with
the hardest song ever that you didn't
know that was
what makes me care it would be huh no
it's like what makes you care exactly
that's that's what's gonna happen that's
what matters more than the song itself
so right you kind of I feel the same way
somebody could walk up to me tomorrow
with a hit record and if I don't know
nothing about them what makes people
were they from or anything I'm gonna be
like that's cool uh yeah hey good luck I
don't see it yeah so that's honestly a
part of the process and especially in
your world like yeah yeah listen the
people that's more motivation so you
gotta understand they're coming to you
out of curiosity too because they're
like wait blue wait Blues new face so
okay so no I know that it's a lot of
like curiosity because a lot of the fans
are like they came from like a whole
different side because a lot a lot of
fans came from like coming from him and
whatever the [__] else he was doing yeah
yeah and which is great great whatever
can help him is great but uh foreign
and it is very important that you do not
let any of the critiques like the one I
just gave you or the comments bother me
no discouraging discourage is the word
because yeah cause that was crazy I
gotta motivate you it's Gotta motivate
you okay I mean listen I've had a way
worse I mean no I'm not I'm not I I'm
glad [__] you know he could tell he's
microt they used to put like dogs behind
my [__] vocals it's crazy it's like
when I interviewed because you know when
I interview him or when I've had him on
my show the people who Pro I can't
believe you had that [__] because
you the first he's a different person
though right freestyle he ever did on
radio ever was on our show really
everything
let me see and listen when I tell you
the [__] people who texted me that
were appalled that I would even give him
a platform oh yeah guys you guys gotta
[__] chill that's more interactional
that's more fun I think it's great I
think that he turns every negative into
a positive so I don't really give a [__]
I mean he embraced the offer he's uh
he's honestly teaching me how to turn
the negative into a positive like you
did because we made this song we made
the song right and he's like what are we
calling it what are we calling I'm like
this is net and then I listen to it and
I said Stewie come on I like him like
come on like like I'm not playing I'm
not I'm not doing none of this [__]
like what it's like everyone's hating
right come on listen you gotta turn it
up like people automatically are gonna
hate on you because of the situation
whether you're good or bad are they
going to say something but also with the
situation people are just automatically
going to hate on you right so all you
got to do is take that and re-re-channel
it into more energy towards making music
yeah I agree
take his advice and listen I I feel like
I really buy bothers you no no okay I
will make sure okay I wasn't trying to
like you know like make it yeah
I think you're you seem solid as [__] I
think you know you got a a good woman
here who's you know 100 raise your kids
and uh I hope hey keep dropping music I
I will that's all you gotta do keep
dropping keep dropping absolutely will
hopefully the illegal situation Source
yourself appreciate that bro
um do you have anything else coming soon
oh [__] move music Jayden Alexis doing
streaming uh is it on uh it's about
everywhere everywhere yeah everywhere
everywhere so more music on everything
I'm doing up next is gonna be Jaden
Alexa soon stay on the lookout for that
and if you're not on the lookout it's
gonna show up on your timeline
too bad no matter what you're gonna see
it
it's gonna be in your head real free
baby you know what y'all should really
do figure out a way to get Drew ski in
the next video
get in the same place that's viral it's
crazy because I was supposed to be at
this party this weekend but I came over
here so I was like yeah I don't care but
they was telling me come to this party I
was like I'll be there if I'm there but
yeah take care of you know blue I gotta
cook breakfast you already know who she
is no I mean of course exactly yeah I
think I saw him say something on Twitter
yeah yeah that's blue face baby I was
wild and that's it
that's my that's my husband I said
whatever that's my other baby mama right
there
baby mama number three right there yeah
it was funny though I agree it was funny
it was funny I don't
there it is appreciate the sit down guys
yes sir house arrest okay man boom
period fire hey appreciate y'all
watching another interview brought to
you by our good Folks at hardean now
listen y'all when you're in Las Vegas
you get in that [__] Uber you land at
the airport hit that taxi tell them to
take you to hardine the number one
premium cannabis dispensary in the
[__] world y'all I'm telling you you
walk in they treat you like a king or a
queen or whatever you're into all right
they got the craziest selection to
premium cannabis you'll see period
anywhere let alone in Las Vegas but just
anywhere all right not only can you go
get the best tree you won't get the best
experience the best customer service the
best bud tenders you walk in the hard
Dean and that [__] just smells amazing
they got their own [__] scent
literally you get into my car I got a
bottle of it my car smells like Harding
because it's just the best [__] place
um go follow them online Harding
underscore Las Vegas
Harding underscore Las Vegas go to their
website
hardinglasvegas.com all right when you
go you're in Vegas you pull up tell them
I sent you they're gonna take care of
you the right way all right look they
got these things in there man these Moon
Rock uh pre-rolls that I just had that
just absolutely melted my face off
shout out to hard Dean all right you
gotta go [__] with hard Dean man Harding
underscore Las Vegas uh thank you all
man I love these guys they're like
family to us and uh hey we're gonna drop
another interview soon if you're
watching this you're at the end of the
interview though much love